what's dad's favorite superhero
apocalypse easy he's water of all bed
dad dad has told how old travel how old
travelled to what BOSU we know what food
does daddy heat expertise I don't see
you eat it before what's dad's favorite
jobs Oh what's dad's daddy's first job
dole Walker oh do what was it wrong
taxi luck never had a job
terrible but he does have a job Pammy
what's dad's middle name wait
what old Durant's like Jermaine so it's
not Garfield I derive garage what choice
does a daddy around the house takes out
the trash when he feels like it
baby what's dad's favorite animal oh
yeah pigeon what where where was daddy
born Brooklyn Brooklyn he was born in
Brooklyn no your study's favorite
musician Stevie Wonder we're on point
today oh yeah daddy's funny yes
No um sometimes lo can daddy saying no
daddy a good driver the plan depends
depends bye guys bye guys my sister
doesn't know what she's talking about
yes yes I do I'm in second grade he's
only in kindergarten
[Music]
you